justement j'ai une question posée tout a
été incarcéré pour trafic de stupéfiants
sur le cac normal le landais toit
de la peine de dorna le landais je serai
quoi une détention à vie
c'est normal pour moi en vrai c'est même
pas une question qui se pose je souffre
vraiment c'est terrible ce qui la fait
vraiment est ce important d'avoir la
ville a pourtant passé que moi quand je
le dis je connais rien à la prison j'ai
jamais à la primaire est scellé lui il a
été donc il sait que la prison c'est dur
et regardez ce qu'il dit dans des tons
sonné les tensions à dix et même peine
qui même pour sa question se pose c'est
normal c'est normal on ne peut pas
laisser un prédateur de la sorte dans la
nature après on va me dire oui peut-être
vont peu on peut vous dire aussi je me
fais l'avocat du diable s'il a mal on
peut vous dire aussi fusé du trafic de
stupéfiants vous avez pu aussi peut-être
tué des gens à cause de deux substances
et de stupéfiants effectués
effectivement mais
on ne sera jamais si je les ai tués ou
pas tandis qu on sait que les a tuées
vous dites voilà c'est vraiment le
criminel c'est l'acte douala ben moi
j'ai vendu des produits stupéfiants
voilà j'étais jeune et ça vous le
regrettez c'est gentil mais on voulait
chercher les super chiant
mais ça c'est pas pareil bien sûr ah oui
j'ai oublié ce que je dis je dis qui est
le plus dépendant le dealer ou le
consommateur parce que le consommateur
et lui veut consommer parce qu'il veut
sa drogue mais le dealer aussi parce
qu'elle a besoin d'argent il vient d'un
milieu un peu précaire il n'a pas trop
donc voilà après pour usure normale mais
en vrai prison à vie pour moi c'est
normal et en plus il est en prison elle
continue à parler avec une fille alors
justement il ya autre chose il a aussi
été questionné sur sa consultation de
sites pornographiques ça avec son
téléphone ils accéderaient ces sites et
favoriserait des catégories sur les
adolescentes et des jeunes filles en
incarcération il reconnaît d'addiction
au sexe explique que sa consultation des
sites pornographiques plusieurs heures
par jour a commencé après l'armée il ça
voilà mais oui on peut parler des
victimes parce qu'on parle jamais des
pièces et ça on peut pas on peut penser
par exemple aux parents de saint brice
exactement c'est aux parents de des cas
il faut y penser bah oui parce que c'est
juste insupportable
à gerber alors je sais pas si c'est des
trous dans la raquette où je sais pas si
c'est de la corruption ou je sais pas si
c'est parce que le travail est mal fait
mais il ya un vrai problème comment ça
c'est qu'ils reçoivent une femme dans le
dans le par et cette femme donc apporte
des choses donc a pas de fouilles en
fait systématique quand quelqu'un est à
l'isoloir le dit dangereux dans le
landais ya pas de flirter l'indiquent
les choses quand vous
il ya des trains des camps n'ont alors
là mais c'est bien je suis content que
vous abordiez le sujet parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui c'est pas que le
professionnalisme des personnels qui à
remettre en question aujourd'hui ces
législateurs qui permettent absolument
ce qu'il a raison aujourd'hui quelqu'un
qui dise au parloir eh ben pour le sait
une simple fouille par palpation famille
et pas quelqu'un par palpation oui
effectivement maze avait 99 % combat
d'unités de rien trouvé il a pratiqué
aujourd'hui une fouille intégrale d'une
personne détenue à la sortie d'un
parloir il faut qu'on puisse pouvoir
prouver que effectivement qu'on suspecte
qui l'a fait rentrer quelque chose et
derrière il ya un formulaire de 50 pages
à remplir c'est parce que notre point de
vue il faut les la malchance dont un
procédurale ça devient donc finalement
du tout et du n'importe quoi donc après
derrière faut pas s'étonner que ça
rentre
derrière sur ce qui s'est passé au
parloir je veux dire que ce soit le
landais que ce soit balkany ou lendemain
le jour où vous avez envie d'avoir une
relation sexuelle au parloir ça arrive
même pour tous la mémoire
d avoir des relations sexuelles au
parloir non c'est interdit mais pour
autant on sait que ça existe en fait
c'est sympa